bonsoir et des libertés au merci d'être
avec nous alors c'est un centenaire on
l'aura compris très difficile à
commémorer certains fait ce qu'ils ont
gagné alors que les autres regrettent
toujours ce qu'ils ont perdu tout à fait
tout est fait pour parler un petit peu
de ces tensions il me semble important
de remonter au tout début l'acte d'union
qui avait été signé en 1801 et à partir
de ces dates-là l'irlande en fait est
unifié à la grande bretagne
et puis en fait c'est à partir de là que
les problèmes vont vont renaître vont
naître puisque des groupes de dissidents
politiques se forme tout au long du
xixème siècle pour demander
l'indépendance
ce qui débouche sur la guerre anglo
irlandaise de 1919 1921 et cette bière
sans vaincu ni vainqueur se termine par
la signature le 6 décembre 1921 du
traité de londres qu'on appelle aussi
traité anglo irlandais qui coupent
l'irlande en deux donc l'irlande du sud
devient un état libre et obtiendra son
indépendance en 1949 et les six comtés
d'irlande du nord quant à eux restent
accrochés au royaume uni donc dans ces
comptes et vivent côte à côte des
nord-irlandais issues de la colonisation
venus des causes donc protestant avec
des nord-irlandais catholique et la
société nord-irlandaise devient petit à
petit une société qui offre des
privilèges aux protestants en ce qui
concerne notamment l'accès à l'éducation
aux emplois au logement et petit à petit
des tensions de plus en plus vives se
développe donc comme la vidéo en faisait
mention entre 1969 et 2009 une période
de violences et d'agitation politique
aussi appelés les troubles déchire les
nord-irlandais et les pertes s'élèvent à
plus de 3500 à 4500 personnes
donc d'un côté les protestants
pro-britanniques en faveur de la
partition surnommés les unionistes de
l'autre les catholiques nord-irlandais
aussi appelé
alors il faut préciser que pardonnez-moi
mais la mise en oeuvre merci pour ce
rappel historique bien nécessaire à
beaucoup certainement d'entre nous la
mise en oeuvre du break site a ravivé
donc les tensions et l'irlande du nord
est dans l'union douanière de l'union
européenne les unionistes se sentent
quoi traille ont aujourd'hui c'est de là
que vient de ces tensions tout à fait
d'autant qu'en 2018 et 2019 le
gouvernement britannique qui était en
pleines négociations avec l'europe avait
promis en fait de ne pas de ne pas
instaurer de contrôle douanier donc la
trahison est d'autant plus vive que les
le gouvernement britannique n'avait pas
du tout prévu sauf au départ lors de la
signature du bric sic alors il faut dire
que le break cité imposer une frontière
de facto entre le royaume uni et les
avants du nord c'est une situation qui
est paradoxal pour les unionistes tout à
fait puisque les unionistes se sentent
comme on l'a vu dans le reportage
britannique est donc finalement c'est en
fait comme si en france on en a on
instaurait une frontière à l'intérieur
de la france donc finalement la trahison
ici et peut se comprendre dans la mesure
où leur propre pays leur impose une
frontière entre les deux clairement on a
vu un ces émeutes qui ont éclaté depuis
le 29 mars
est ce que ces violences risquent de
fragiliser clairement la stabilité du
pays
alors elle le risque oui tout à fait
puisque bon nous l'avons vu aussi dans
le reportage 90 officiers de police sont
blessés donc déjà sondé violence assez
bas qui crée en fait qui augmente le
nombre de morts et de pertes et surtout
qui ravive qui font revenir à la vie
un petit peu ce passé qui avait été qui
avait été au tour de notamment autour de
la question de l'identité qui avait été
un petit peu étouffé par les accords de
1998 et donc les problèmes resurgissent
et notamment parmi les jeunes qui se
font manipuler par des groupes
paramilitaires et des et des gangs
criminels en fait
merci emilie berthillot je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur est maître de
conférences en civilisation britannique
contemporaine à l'université de lille
merci d'avoir été avec nous